We've been working our way through Plato's arguments for the immortality of the
soul and last time I spent a fair bit of time working through objections to uh,
not quite the last argument we're going to look at,
but the pen ultimate argument,
which Plato tries to argue for the simplicity of the soul,
the set of connected ideas you recall were these,
that Plato wants to suggest that in order to be destroyed,
you've got to have parts to destroy something is to basically sort of take its
parts apart.
If he could only convince us that the soul was simple,
it would follow that it was indestructable and hence immortal.
You asked what's our evidence for some things being in disruptable?
What kinds of things are simple while these are,
he then goes on to claim invisible things.
Things that don't change after all.
Changing is a matter of the rearrangement of the parts.
And so if something can change,
it can't be simple.
Maybe it could be destroyed.
But if we could become convinced that the soul was not composite,
if it was something that did,
couldn't change,
than it would be simple.
Perhaps then it would be in disruptable.
And then he goes on to suggest that the invisibility of the soul is evidence for
its being.
Changeless enhance simple and hence indestructable.
So that's the argument we worked through last time and I spent a fair bit of
time suggesting that if you pin down precisely what Plato means by invisible,
the argument doesn't actually go through
before leaving at argument.
There's a couple of extra remarks I want to make about it.
First,
we probably shouldn't have been so quick to want to buy into this suggestion
that the soul is changeless after all.
If you think about it,
it seems that at least on the face of it,
the soul does indeed change on one day.
You believe,
for example,
that a,
it's hot on another day.
You believe that it's cold on one day.
Uh,
you believe that you know,
so and so a is a nice person on the next day.
I believe that so and so's a mean person.
You're you,
you desire to learn the piano the next day you give up on that desire,
your beliefs,
your goals,
your intentions,
your desires.
These things are all constantly changing and so at least on the face of it,
it looks as though we might well want to say the soul.
If we do believe there are souls,
the soul is changing as well in terms of what thoughts and beliefs it's housing,
so we should have been skeptical in the first place of any argument that said,
based on the invisibility of the soul,
we can conclude that it's changeless doesn't seem to be in fact changeless.
Furthermore,
we should be,
or at least we might well be skeptical of the claim that the soul is simple.
Indeed,
Plato himself in other dialogues argues against the simplicity of the soul.
Now,
that doesn't mean he's right in other dialogues,
but at least suggests that we shouldn't be so ready to assume that that sort of
position is correct.
In the republic famously played.
It goes on to argue that the soul has at least three different parts.
There's a rational part that's control,
that's in charge of reasoning.
There's a spirited part that sort of like the will.
There's an APP,
a part that has to do with appetite.
Uh,
the desires for food,
drink,
sex,
what have you.
Plato elsewhere argues the soul is not simple at all.
So perhaps it shouldn't shock us that the argument he's sketching here for the
simplicity of the soul based on the changeless and visible nature of the soul,
perhaps it shouldn't shock us that that argument doesn't succeed after all.
Finally,
although I gave Plato previously the assumption that if only we could establish
the simplicity of the soul,
it would follow.
The soul was indestructable after all,
you couldn't break a soul by tearing it's pieces apart.
If it didn't have pieces,
if it didn't have parts.
Nonetheless,
I just want to register the thought that it's not actually obvious that simple's
can't be destroyed.
Well,
they clearly can't be destroyed by the particular method of destruction that
involves taking them apart.
They don't have parts,
you can't take them apart.
But for all that,
it still seems conceptually possible for a simple to be destroyed in the
following sense.
It goes out of existence.
After all.
Where did the simples come from in the first place?
Well,
at least from a logical point of view,
it seems as though there's no difficulty in imagining that at one point a given
simple didn't exist and then at the next point it popped into existence.
Well,
how did that happen?
Maybe God said,
you know,
God says the beginning of Genesis,
let there be light.
You know,
so maybe he says,
let there be symbols right given moment.
They weren't there the next moment they were.
Well after a while,
maybe God says,
let the simples no longer exist given moment there they were the next moment
they no longer exist.
Seems as though that idea makes sense.
And so even if we agreed that the soul was simple,
even if we granted everything in Plato's argument up to this point and said,
there's soul really is simple,
it's still wouldn't follow that it's a mortal.
We'd still have to worry about the possibility that the simple soul might simply
pop out of existence at a given point,
perhaps the very point when the body gets destroyed.
So I'm inclined to think that this most recent argument of Plato's,
the argument from simplicity that's not successful either.
Before that argument,
there's one other piece of business.
I want to discuss this as a footnote that I put aside or a a point that I put
aside previously.
You'll recall that we were worried about the objection got raised,
that the right way to think about the soul is like the harmony of a harp.
And this was originally offered as a counter example to,
uh,
the,
the thought that invisible things couldn't be destroyed,
but harmony could be destroyed.
It was invisible.
So invisible things could be destroyed.
But I noticed,
I mentioned that,
look,
whether or not this is a problem for the argument,
it's an interesting suggestion in its own right because the suggestion that the
mind is to the body,
the soul is to the body.
Like harmony is to a,
an instrument with strings seems to need to be an early attempt to describe
something like the physicalist conception of the mind just as harmony is
something that gets produced by a well tuned instrument.
The soul or the mind is something that gets produced by a well tuned body.
Now Plato's got some objections to the suggestion that we should think of the
mind as the harmony of the body and so I want to take just a moment and talk
about those objections because of course if they were compelling objections that
might well give us reason to doubt the physicalist view whether or not play
those arguments for the immortality of the soul work.
He might still have some good arguments against the physicalist conception,
but in thinking about these objections,
it's important to bear in mind that it's only meant the harmony analogies only
meant as just that as an analogy,
right?
The claim isn't,
or at least it shouldn't be understood as sane.
Literally the mind is harmony.
It's rather the mind is like harmony.
It's the sort of thing to the body like harmony is to a harp up something that
can be produced by a well functioning,
well tuned physical object.
A well tuned instrument can produce melody and harmony are well tuned.
Properly functioning body can produce mental activity.
That's the suggestion and so even if it turns out that there are some ways in
which the mind isn't exactly like harmony doesn't show us that the physical list
views wrong,
we'll still,
let's quickly look at what Plato's arguments were first.
This is I think an interesting argument.
Plato says harmony clearly cannot exist before the existence of the harp itself,
right?
The melodious ness of the harp can't exist prior to the physical construction of
the harp
and if mind where the sort of thing that were pro that was produced by the
proper functioning of the body,
then pretty obviously the mind could not exist prior to the creation of the
physical body.
However,
okay.
Plato has already argued earlier in the dialog that the soul does exist prior to
the existence of the body.
That's the argument from recollection.
Soul exists prior to the body.
It can't be like harmony.
Physicalism is clearly gotta be false.
Okay.
But I said that I didn't find the argument.
I tried to explain why I didn't find the argument from recollection persuasive.
I certainly do want to agree that if we became convinced that the soul did exist
prior to the existence of the body,
we would certainly want to agree that the soul is not like harmony.
But I don't think the argument from recollection succeeds.
Plato's second objection is to point out that harmony can vary.
You know,
we talk about the melodious newness of the,
the harp will,
it can be harmonious in a variety of different ways and indeed to different
degrees.
Yeah.
Something,
an instrument can be more or less harmonious.
What it's playing can be in greater or lesser harmony,
but it doesn't seem as though souls come in degrees.
You've got a soul,
you don't have a soul.
That's the argument.
That's the objection.
You've got a mind you don't have in mind.
Yeah,
but perhaps we should.
That's the objection.
Of course.
If that was right,
then again,
we might have to conclude,
well,
whatever the mind is,
it's not quite like harmony is to the body,
but I'm not so sure we should agree that the mind can't come in degrees.
It can at least the,
the mental aspects can come in degrees.
We can have varying degrees of intelligence,
varying degrees of creativity,
varying degrees of reasonableness,
varying degrees of ability to communicate.
So just as we might say,
just as the functioning of the harp can come in varying degrees,
more or less harmony.
Yeah.
The functioning of the body in terms of its mind can come in varying degrees.
So that second objection doesn't seem to me very compelling.
Third Objection.
Yeah.
Plato points out,
Socrates points out that the soul can be good or it could be evil.
Wicked.
When the soul is good,
when you've got somebody who's sort of got their stuff together,
we might speak of them having a harmonious soul.
Okay.
If the soul were to the body like harmony is to the instrument and the soul can
be harmonious,
it would seem as though we'd have to be able to talk about harmony being
harmonious.
Okay,
so just as we can talk about the harmony of the soul,
we'd have to be able to,
if the soul is like the harmony of the body,
we'd have to go to talk about the harmony of the harmony,
but we don't talk about harmony of the harmony,
not quite sure what to make of this objection.
This might be a point where it'd be well to remind ourselves of the fact that
the suggestion was never that the soul just literally is harmony.
It's just similar to harmony says the physical list in the way that harmony gets
produced by the body,
by the,
by the instrument.
In that same way,
mind or mental activity gets produced by the body.
We don't have to say that everything that's true of the mind is true of harmony.
Everything that's true,
harmony is true of the body or the mind still.
I think there's a bit more we can say in response to this objection.
That's this.
Yeah.
Just as it's true that we can talk about minds or souls being good or wicked,
we can talk about different kinds of harmony.
There's
certain harmonies are sweeter than others.
Some of them are more jarring and a tone or discord,
although we might not normally talk about how harmonious the harmony is.
It seems as though harmonies can come in different sorts of different kinds,
and then it turns out that really what happened in the allergy to the mind,
which can come in different sorts and different kinds.
So I think this third objection isn't really compelling either.
Finally,
yeah,
Plato Racist,
one more objection.
He says,
look,
the sole is capable of directing the body,
bossing it around,
and indeed capable of opposing the body.
Know your,
your body might want that piece of chocolate cake,
but your soul says,
no,
you're on a diet.
Don't eat it.
All right.
Your soul can oppose the body.
But if the soul was just harmony of the body,
how can it do that?
After all,
the harmoniousness of the harp can't affect what the harp does.
The Ha,
it's all the,
all the causal interactions.
One way as we might put it in the case of the harp and the and the musicality
and the melodious and and the harmony,
the physical state of the harp causes the melodious and this to be the way it
is,
but the harmoniousness of the harp doesn't ever change or alter or direct the
way the physical object to harp is.
Okay.
In contrast,
not only can the body affect the soul,
the soul can affect the body,
so that's ingested,
can't really be like harmony and the harp after all.
I think that's a pretty interesting objection since we do think at least in the
kind of position that we've been taking for this class that the soul can affect
the body.
We might ask how could it be that it's that the physical list view is right.
If,
if talk about the mind is just a way of talking about what the body can do,
how can the abilities of the body affect the body itself?
I think the answer to this objection is probably going to be something like,
yeah,
what's really going on when we talk about the soul affecting the body is that
when we say certain functions of the body are affecting the body,
there are certain mental functions are affecting the body.
How does this happen causally?
Well,
something like the physical parts of the body that underwrite that lie beneath
the proper functioning,
the proper mental functioning of the body,
those are able to alter the other parts of the body.
So look right now I'm telling my body,
wiggle my fingers.
My soul is getting instructions to my body.
How does that happen?
That's my mind giving instructions to my body.
How does that happen on the physical list view?
Well,
my mind giving instructions and my body wiggle.
My fingers is just one part of my body.
My brain giving instructions to another part of my body,
the muscles in my fingers.
So although we talk about the mind altering the body strictly what's going on
there,
it says the physical list is just one part of the body affecting another part of
the body.
Okay.
Can we have something like that with a harp?
Well,
you know,
maybe not.
Right.
Maybe.
Maybe the harps too simple.
A machine to have one part of it affect another part of it in that way.
Even if that was true,
that wouldn't give us reason to the physicalist conception.
It would just give us reason to think.
The harps not very much like the mind and the body.
It's just the beginnings of a picture of a physicalist picture still.
Even if we think about the harp and musicality,
I think we can see something analogous.
Suppose I pluck a string on my harp producing a certain note.
As we know the vibrations of one string can set into play the other strings
vibrating as well.
Okay,
and so suddenly what's happening in one part of the harp affects what's going on
in other parts of the harp.
The musicality of my plane is certain chord on the harp may create certain kinds
of overtones in the harp setting,
the harp vibrating and various other ways.
Well,
that would be analogous.
Perhaps not a precise analogy,
but at least a rough analogy to what goes on when my mind affects my body to it.
One part of my body affects other parts of my body.
So
on the one hand I want to give Plato a fair bit of credit for taking the
physical list view seriously enough to try to criticize it.
And since when he was writing it,
then,
you know the word,
the kind of complicated thinking machines that we've got nowadays.
It's no criticism of Plato that he used simple machines like musical instruments
to try to think about what a physical his picture would look like.
Want to give him credit,
but also want to suggest that the objections that he raises to the physicalist
view just don't succeed.
Okay.
All right.
Now there's one other argument that I want to consider in our dialogue and after
the appeal to the simplicity of the soul,
there's a very long complicated discussion about what constitutes an adequate
explanation.
And Socrates gives some of his,
uh,
his history there and talks about what he's looking for and trying to find
adequate explanations of things.
And these passages are very,
very difficult and you know,
happily for our purposes,
we don't really need to go there before the dialogue ends though.
There's one further argument which I'll dub the argument from essential
properties.
Now again,
it's important to bear in mind is we tried to make sense of this passage that
Plato is writing at a time when,
okay,
we don't have,
we didn't have all the conceptual apparatus that we have nowadays.
We are,
we stand on his shoulders.
We've inherited some of the distinctions that he was the first to try to into
play
and so although again,
he's about to,
I'm about to sketch a,
reconstruct an argument and and claim that the argument doesn't actually work is
isn't really meant by way of dis be dismissive of Plato.
I wanted to give him a tremendous amount of credit.
He's trying to see his way through a morass of issues that are still confusing
to us today.
Though I think we can see somewhat further than he was able to see any rate.
That distinction,
we need to understand.
The final argument is the distinction between an essential property and a
contingent property.
And essential property is a property that again,
an object must have.
It always has as long as it exists at all.
A contingent property is a property that an object may have,
may happen to have its entire existence,
but could have existed without.
So my car is blue,
that's a contingent property of my car.
I could take it to the paint shop and get it painted red,
in which case it wouldn't be red,
it would no longer be blue,
but the car would still exist.
My car is blue,
but it could be red,
it could exist as a red car.
And even if I never over the entire course of existence of my car,
never get it painted.
So that from the moment it came into creation to the moment gets smashed.
It's always blue.
Still,
we understand perfectly well the idea that it could have been read it if there's
nothing to incompatible with the idea that this car exists and is red.
So that's an example of a contingent property.
And you know,
I might have a pencil and the pencil is,
is uh,
is whole and I never break it,
but I could have broken it.
That's contingent property.
Whether the Pencil is whole or broken.
I take a piece of metal,
it's contingent property,
whether it's straight or bent,
my bend it now it's bent.
I might straighten back out.
Now it's straight.
Many,
many properties are contingent properties.
You're happy,
you're sad,
you're awake,
you're asleep.
But some properties and contrast are essential properties for the particular
thing that we're thinking about.
It's not possible to have that thing and not have the property in question
played or gives the example of fire and being hot.
Fire is hot.
That's a property that it's God,
but it's not a contingent property.
It's an essential property.
It's not as though some fire is hot and some fire is cold or oh yes,
it just happens.
It over the entire life of the fire.
The fire is hot,
but we could have made it cold.
There was no such thing.
There could be no such thing as cold fire.
As long as you got a bit of fire.
It's hot.
Take away the heat.
You take away the fire,
you destroy the fire.
You can't have cold fire.
That's an example of an essential property.
They say Plato sees as an D.
I take it.
We all see at least roughly that there's some sort of distinction there and he's
trying to see his way clear on these matters.
That's a remains.
A controversial question today until today are they're really essential
properties and the way we take their to be.
If so,
which properties are essential?
Which ones are contingent?
Water's composed of h two o.
That's its atomic structure.
Is that an essential property of water?
Could you have something that was water without being composed of h two o
hydrogen and oxygen and that way?
No.
Some people say yes.
Some people say no,
but it most of us who want to say,
oh,
there's an example of an essential property to be water.
You must have that atomic structure.
All right.
That's the thought.
Now armed with this distinction,
Plato says,
here's any essential property for the soul.
Wherever there's a soul.
Yeah,
it's alive
now by alive.
I take it,
Plato means it's thinking or it's capable of thought.
Wherever you've got a soul,
you've got something capable of thought.
Okay.
I suppose one could try to resist this claim of Plato's,
but I find it reasonably plausible.
I start thinking about mines and I asked myself,
could there be a mind that was incapable of thought?
Yeah,
maybe,
maybe not.
Maybe that sort of just sort of built in to mines.
By definition,
we're just like,
you couldn't have something that was fire without it being hot,
so you couldn't have something that was a mind without.
It's being capable of thought.
Important to say the word capable here,
right?
Not.
It's not as though all mine's always are thinking.
I presumed there are stretches during the night when my mind is not thinking,
not dreaming.
Still it's capable of thought,
even though it's not thinking at the time,
but
you say,
no,
here's a mine that's not even capable of thought I want to say.
Then it's just not a mine.
So all right.
Maybe being capable of thought is an essential property of the mind.
Plato thinks about the mind in terms of souls,
so maybe being capable of thoughts and essential property of the soul.
And I think that's what played on means when he suggests the mind is essentially
the sole is essentially alive.
It's a necessary property as we might put it,
of the soul,
that it's alive and it's capable of thoughts.
So to say,
loud an implausible claim,
let's give it to Socrates.
But once we give it to Socrates,
Plato thinks now he's pretty much done.
After all,
think about what it means to say that something's got an essential property.
Fires got the essential property of being hot.
I mean it's the only two possibilities.
Either you've got some fire and it will be hot or the fire's been destroyed.
It's been put out.
There was the only two possibilities you'll either have,
if,
if heat is an essential property of fire,
either you've got some fire and it's hot or the fire no longer exists.
It's been put out.
There's no third possibility of a non hot fire of a cold fire.
So if you've got the claim that life's in essential property of the soul,
only two possibilities.
Either you've got the soul and it's alive to it.
It's capable of thought
or this soul's been destroyed,
but Plato thinks we can rule out that other possibility.
How well it's by thinking about this particular essential property.
There's nothing in the idea that fire has the essential property of being hot to
make us think it couldn't be destroyed.
But there is something Plato thinks in the idea of being essentially alive to
rule out the possibility of it's being destroyed.
In fact,
as you say the very words,
you begin to feel the horse,
the pool of Plato's position,
if the soul is essentially alive,
if it's necessarily alive,
it's got to be alive.
Okay?
Can't be destroyed.
That's,
I think,
at least the kind of argument that played a means to put forward.
He does it in terms of the phrase deathless.
Okay,
says,
let's actually get this up here.
The board one
life
is an essential property of the soul,
but if you think about what that means,
it follows that the soul is deathless
after office.
Soul.
If it's essentially alive,
that means a can't be dead.
So it's deathless.
Okay.
But after all,
anything that's deathless can't die.
So the soul cannot die,
which is just to say it's indestructable.
So soul cannot be destroyed.
Okay.
Something like this seems to be played,
those argument,
one license,
essential property of the soul.
But we can just summarize that by saying the soul is deathless,
but the soul deathless it can't die.
It can't die,
can't be destroyed.
It's indestructible,
so the soul cannot be destroyed.
I remember once we said the soul was alive,
there are only two possibilities.
So it was essentially alive.
Either we have the soul,
it's alive,
capable of thought,
or it's destroyed.
But if the soul cannot be destroyed,
that leaves only the possibility the soul is alive,
capable of thought.
That's just what Plato thinks.
The soul will always exist capable of thought.
Well,
won't shock you to hear that.
I don't think this argument actually works.
And I think where it goes wrong is there's a certain kind of ambiguity
in the idea of being deathless.
What does it mean to say that something is deck lists?
I think there's two possible interpretations of that phrase.
If something is deathless,
then it can't be that.
Well,
what one possibility is it can't be the sole exists and his dad.
That's one possible interpretation to say that something is deathless means
you'll never have a soul that exists at the same time that it exists.
It's dead,
but there's a second possible
interpretation of deathless.
It can't be that.
Okay,
so was destroyed.
Very easy to confuse these two interpretations of deathless a and B.
Okay?
And basically this is what I think is going on with Plato.
He's running back and forth between these two interpretations.
If life is an essential property of the soul,
then that means we will never have,
you know as or a soul in our hand that exists and is dead
just in the same way that you'll never have a piece of fire in your hand as it
were that exists and is cold,
can't happen wherever you've got a soul,
it is alive.
So it's deathless incense number sense,
a,
since wherever you've got a soul,
it must be alive.
It couldn't be the case that the soul exists.
And is dead.
Yeah,
so the deathless in Sensei,
but for all of that,
it could still be logically speaking that the soul could be destroyed just like
the fire can be put out.
We could imagine something that couldn't be destroyed.
Yeah.
Then of course it would be death listen sense be a much stronger sense of
deathless.
Okay.
What Plato needs,
what Plato wants is to convince us that the soul is deathless incense.
B.
That's true of the soul,
that it can't be that it was destroyed,
but all he's entitled to his Sensei.
You'll never have a soul that exists and is dead because being alive and
essential property of the soul,
but the mere fact that where there's a soul,
it's alive,
it doesn't mean the sole couldn't be destroyed.
Just like from the fact that where there's fire,
it's hot doesn't mean the fire can't be destroyed.
Okay.
They say it's I think,
pretty easy to get confused in thinking about these issues.
It's difficult to see your way clearly to these two different notions of
deathless.
It's difficult to get to a point where you can clearly use the language of
essential properties without getting screwed up still.
I think that's what happened here.
We grant Plato the thought that the soul has an essential property being alive
from this.
It follows that where there's a soul,
it is alive and hence it's deathless in Sansei,
but once we started thinking about the category,
the notion of being deathless,
we're tempted to re understand that as being deathless incense be can't be
destroyed and that I think doesn't follow.
All right,
where does that leave us?
Okay.
Plato's gone through a series of arguments for the immortality,
the indestructibility of the soul,
and I've argued that none of them work.
Some of them are worth taking seriously.
That's why we've spent the last week or so going over them,
but none of them as far as I can see are successful and I hardly need to remind
you that this comes on the heels of your previous week or two in which we talked
about various other arguments for the very existence of an immaterial soul.
And I've argued that none of those arguments work either as far as I can see.
Then the arguments that might be offered for the existence of an in the arterial
soul,
let alone an immortal soul.
The arguments don't succeed.
It's not that the idea of a soul is in any way silly.
It's not that it's not worth thinking about.
It's that when we ask ourselves,
do we have any good reason to believe in an immaterial soul and actually try to
spell out what those reasons might be.
As we look more carefully,
we see the arguments are not very compelling.
So I'm prepared to conclude there is no soul,
there's no good reason to believe in souls.
And so I conclude at least there's no good enough reason to believe in souls.
And so I conclude there are none.
Yeah,
and this is the position that sort of here on out,
I'm going to be assuming for the rest of the class,
I'm going to have us continue to think about death,
but now think about death from the physical list perspective.
Given the assumption that the body is all there is that talk about the mind is
just a way of talking about the abilities of the body to do certain special
mental activities.
There are no extra things beyond the body.
No immaterial souls
now wouldn't be unreasonable at this point to accuse me of begging the question.
After all I think about what I've done.
I put all of the burden of proof on the fan of souls are the asked the the dual
list.
Give me some reason to believe your position and they've said the arguments on
behalf of dualism aren't very convincing.
Dominate.
I now need and fairness to do the same thing for the physical list.
Don't I need to turn to the physicalist and say,
give me some reason to believe that physical,
isn't this true?
Give me some reason to believe souls don't exist.
After all,
I turned to the dual list and said,
give me some reason to believe in souls.
Those arguments didn't work.
Don't I now need to turn to the physical list and say,
give me some reason not to believe in souls.
Prove that souls don't exist.
Isn't that fair?
Okay,
so let's pause and ask ourselves.
How do you go about proving that something doesn't exist or to put it in a
slightly better way,
when do you need to prove that something doesn't exist?
When we
have examples of things whose existence we don't believe in,
how do we decide when we're justified in disbelieving them?
Take something like dragons.
Let me assume that everybody in this class in this room does not believe in the
existence of dragons.
How do I prove that there aren't any dragons?
I mean,
could be dragons couldn't there,
but there aren't any.
You don't believe in dragons,
so don't you need to disprove the existence of dragons before you continue on
your way of not believing in them?
I imagine nobody in this room believes in the existence of Zeus,
the Greek God.
How do you disprove the existence of Zeus?
Okay.
Don't we have an obligation to prove that Zeus doesn't exist,
but,
but how could you do that?
Well,
I'm surprisingly,
I don't actually think you do have an obligation to disprove those things.
It doesn't mean you don't have any obligations.
Just have to be very careful about what the intellectual obligations come to.
So back to dragons.
What do we need to do for dragons?
Well,
the most important thing you need to do to justify your skepticism about dragons
is to refute all of the arguments that might be offered on behalf of dragons.
My son's got a book about dragons with some very nice photographs.
So one of the things I need to do in order to justify my skepticism about
dragons is explain away the photographs I need or the,
you know,
the,
the good drawings or what have you.
I need to explain why it is that we have pictures,
even though there really aren't any dragons.
Well,
you know,
some of these are just drawings and people were drawing things out of their
imagination.
The things that look like photographs,
you know,
nowadays with computer generated graphics you can make things that look like
photographs and given Photoshop you can make things look like,
uh,
you know,
pictures or just about anything that doesn't even exist.
Okay.
How do I prove there aren't any UNICORNS?
Well,
I look at the various reported sightings of Unicorns and I try to explain them
away.
Well,
you know,
first time people,
European saw the rhinoceros sort of reminded them of a horse with a,
you know,
a big horn.
And maybe that's why the reports that were Nasir bus came,
all the various unit reports to the Unicorn came from the various unicorn horns
that had been offered,
you know,
in uh,
in various collections.
Upon examination by biologists turn out to be nar wall horn,
certain horns from Wales and so forth and so on.
You look at each bit of evidence that gets offered on behalf of the,
and you debunk it.
You explain why it's not compelling
and when you're done,
you're entitled to say,
you know,
as far as I can tell,
there aren't any UNICORNS.
As far as I can tell,
there aren't any dragons.
It's not as though you've got some obligation to look in every single cave
anywhere on the surface of the earth.
And so not no dragons in there,
no dragons in there,
no dragons,
and there no dragons.
And there you're pretty much justified in being skeptical about the existence of
dragons.
Once you've undermined the arguments for dragons.
Now there might be something more that you could do in at least some cases you
can go on to argue.
The very idea of the kind of thing we're talking about is impossible.
It's not just take take dragons.
Again,
it's not just that there's no good reason to believe in dragons.
The very idea of a dragon may be scientifically and coherent,
at least given the science as we understand it.
I mean dragons I supposed to breathe fire.
So that must mean that got fire in their belly.
But how does the fire continue to exist in their belly?
You know,
absent Latin,
the lack of oxygen,
why isn't the fire in their belly busy?
You know,
burning and destroying the membranes of their stomach or whatever.
Right?
You could,
I suppose,
try to prove that dragons were scientifically impossible
and if you could,
then you'd have an extra reason to not believe in them.
But it's not as though you have to prove that something's impossible to be
justified in not believing in it.
I don't think Unicorns are impossible.
Yeah,
I just don't think there are any.
Surely there could be horses with a single long horn growing out of their
forehead.
There just aren't any.
Yeah.
So armed with these ideas,
come back to the discussion of souls.
Do I as a physical list who does not believe in the existence of souls,
in material entities above and beyond the body?
Do I need to disprove the existence of souls?
Well,
it was no soul here.
No souls there.
Know what I need to do is to take a look at each argument that gets offered for
the existence of a soul.
Andrew brought it.
Explain why those arguments are not compelling.
I don't need to prove that souls are impossible.
I just need to undermine the case for souls.
If there's no good reason to believe in souls,
that actually constitutes a reason to believe there are no souls.
Now,
if you want to,
you could go on and try to prove that souls are impossible in the same way that
maybe dragons are impossible,
but I'm not sure that I myself fine.
Such impossibility claims,
especially persuasive.
I don't believe in the existence of souls,
but that doesn't mean that I find the idea of an immaterial entity like the soul
impossible.
Now,
some people might say,
well,
you know,
it violates science as we know it.
It violates physics to have the be something immaterial.
Yeah,
but science is constantly coming around to believe in entities or properties
that it didn't believe in previously.
Maybe it just hasn't gotten around to believing in souls yet.
Or if current signs rules out the possibility of souls,
maybe we should say so much the worse for current science.
Okay,
so I'm not somebody who wants to say we can disprove the existence of souls.
I don't think we can disprove them.
I don't think the idea of a soul is in any way in coherent.
There are philosophers who thought that I'm not one of them,
but I don't think I need to disprove the existence of a soul to be justified in
not believing in it.
UNICORNS aren't impossible,
but for all that I'm justified in thinking there aren't any.
Why?
Because all the evidence for Unicorns just doesn't add up to very convincing
case.
Souls are not impossible.
But for all that,
I think I'm justified in believing there.
Our antennae.
Why?
Because when you look for the art,
look at the arguments that have been offered to try to convince us of the
existence of souls.
Those arguments just aren't very compelling or so it seems to me.
So from this point on out,
I'll be assuming the physical list view is correct,
and we'll be thinking about the issues of death as they'd be understood from the
physical list point of view.